ja ich begrüße sie zur heutigen sitzung
am 20
mai in der wir uns mit avi senna und
thomas von aquin befassen werden und
ihre auffassung darüber was existenz ist
das ist die thematik des seminars und
wir begeben uns heute ins mittelalter
und haben da ganz interessante dinge die
wir ein bisschen näher kennenlernen
wollen
zunächst möchte ich aber noch mal eine
rück im rückblick geben auf die letzte
sitzung da haben wir sehr schwierige
texte gelesen von diesem herrn heer von
aristoteles war wie sie wissen schüler
von platon und was gibt's zu aristoteles
zu sagen erst mal die metaphysik das ist
ja sein hauptwerk so hat aristoteles das
nicht genanntes werk sie nennt sich das
ist eine bezeichnung die nach
aristoteles erst in die philosophie
geschichte eingegangen ist alles totaler
spricht nur von dem was nach der physik
ist bzw er spricht eigentlich von einer
prima philosophie also von einer ersten
philosophie und diese rede von
metaphysik das was nach der metaphysik
ist das ist eigentlich nur eine
biografische beschreibung von forscher
und könnte man sagen die nach
aristoteles versucht haben sein werk zu
systematisieren
aber man kann da natürlich trotzdem
sagen das was nach der metaphysik das
was nach der physik kommt wie bei mir
hier oben wenn das jetzt hier die physik
ist dann ist das die metaphysik
das wird schon seinen grund gehabt haben
warum das danach kam der biograf oder
forscher hat sich dabei schon etwas
gedacht dieser systematisieren
dh die ordnung jetzt in der bibliothek
oder im werkverzeichnis die hat auch
einen inhaltlichen grund und der
inhaltliche grund ist der dass eben in
der physik dasjenige behandelt wird was
körperlich ist und was dadurch eben
denken sie ein platon körperliche dinge
sind vergänglich
wir sind ja nicht so stabil und das was
nach der physik kommt ist dann bei
aristoteles das was eben sich mit
solchen gegenständen oder themen befasst
die nicht so vergänglich sind wie die
physikalischen gegenstände
ja und dann haben wir uns das hier
angeschaut das habe ich einen 21 kuchen
genannt das heißt nach aristoteles
betrachten die spezial wissenschaften
wie die physik eben nur das seien die
insofern ist bestimmte eigenschaften
aufweist als sie zum beispiel in sofern
die physikalische körperliche
eigenschaften haben die mathematik hat
es nicht mit körperlichen dingen zu tun
die hat es mit abstrakten dingen zu tun
von die psychologie hat es mit
seelischen dingen zu tun sie könnten
hier sich genauso gut noch vorstellen
hier die biologie einzuzeichnen die
biologie hat es mit geologischen dinge
also lebendigen dingen zu tun das
natürlich dann die frage wie verhält das
zu psychologie sie sehen es geht um das
sei insofern es bestimmte eigenschaften
hat und jetzt gibt es eben noch eine
ganz grundsätzliche wissenschaft die man
nach aristoteles die metaphysik nennt
und in der lateinischen technologie die
anthologie bzw
und luisa auch griechisch also die
praktisch metaphysiker general ist das
ist die lateinische bezeichnung also die
generelle wissenschaft die sich mit dem
sein denn grundsätzlich befasst in
sofern es überhaupt ist und das wäre
dann gewissermaßen dieser randhir und
diese wissenschaft die betrachtet nicht
dass seine in bestimmten hinsichten nach
lebendig oder physikalisch oder
mathematisch sind einfach dass sein als
sein dass schlechthin sein schlechthin
und da hängt natürlich auch das thema
existenz mit zusammen ja und das haben
uns angeschaut und dann haben wir
gesehen obwohl das seien der begriff des
einst so allgemein ist naja das ist
vielleicht der allgemeine begriff
behaupten wir können ja nur über etwas
sprechen wenn wir sagen dass es
irgendwie ist zumindest möglich ist
unmöglich ist aber wie
müssen immer das wort ist verwenden wenn
wir überhaupt über etwas sprechen
und obwohl es so allgemein ist das thema
sein kann man doch und das zeigt
aristoteles ist klar noch weitere dinge
in abhebung bringen von diesem ganz
allgemeinen existenzform und das sind
zum beispiel nach aristoteles die zehn
kategorien
da haben wir gesagt zuerst am
wichtigsten ist die kategorie der
substanz das ist das tier zum beispiel
das ist die subjekte schilling satz
nachdem man fragen wer oder was
dann gibt es die quantität die größe als
das pferd wiegt eine tonne wie viel
gibt's die qualität hat malte schwarz
könnte vielleicht auch sagen das pferd
ist schnell ein gutes pferd die relation
das pferd liegt zwölf mal so viel wie
ich der ort versteht das befindet es
sich wann die lage steht und das haben
es hat einen sattel und das tun was geht
von ihm für eine aktivität aus und das
leiden was für eine aktivität wirkt auf
dieses subjekt auf die substanz ein
hier kann man sich natürlich fragen sind
das wirklich alles alle kategorien die
man dem seine zu sprechen kann
oder fehlt ja nicht eine oder man kann
doch noch anders fragen ist vielleicht
eine kategorie in einer anderen bereits
enthalten ist es also vollständig das
ist eine riesen debatte die sich da im
anschluss an aristoteles ergeben hat
darf man an immanuel kant auf den
kommentar auch zu sprechen er sagte im
aristo des hat diese kategorien nur
willkürlich ohne systematischen
zusammenhang aufgezählt und das ist in
sich nicht stimmig
ja gut kann man sich natürlich kann man
darüber diskutieren aber was ich sehr
einleuchtend finde ist dass hier die
substanz am anfang steht und das
leuchtet er ein aufgrund der grammatik
der syntax in einem satz die
satzstellung also der satz glied
das ist immer das auf dass ich alles
beziehen wenn sie einen text übersetzen
schauen sie über nachdem das objekt dann
schauen sie nach dem prädikat und dass
sie das immer nach dem subjekt zunächst
nicht suchen müssen deutet das darauf
hin dass die substanz und so logisch
eine besondere relevanz hat das ist sein
besonders ausgezeichnet dass sein ist
wenn es um die substanz geht und nicht
so sehr jetzt um eine bloße quantität
also wie viel oder so das hat eine
gewisse plausibilität
das sind die kategorien des seins und
jetzt gibt es noch die bedeutung von
seien die aristoteles auch als eine der
ersten sehr treffend voneinander
abgehoben hat und da kann man zunächst
einmal nennen seinem cd existenz als
peter ist er existiert und das ist der
sinn von sein mit dem wir uns vor allem
befassen wollen diesem seminar dann gibt
es den sinn von sein der die der
identität meint also peter ist derjenige
genau der der und nur der der immer
montags zu späten die vorleser kommt
oder der sich zu spät bei zoom ein
klingt dann gibt es noch eine weitere
bedeutung und diese drei die die hat
alles tolle sicherlich im blick die
identität betrachtet er nicht so
intensiv aber die predigt also alle ist
heute gut gelaunt das wäre wenn sie noch
mal zurück denken auf die kategorien
lehre sich beziehen wäre dass die
qualität wie ist das dann nicht wie
viele sind wie anne ist heute gut
gelaunt das also das prädikat und dann
gibt es noch einen vierten sinn und zwar
der wahrheit' also das vegetative sein
es ist man kann ergänzen so wie ich es
sage das ist so ja
und im grunde genommen wenn sie mal
genau hinschauen jeder satz den man
überhaupt behaupten des todes sozusagen
apodiktisch einsatz der scheint wenn er
ernst gemeint ist schon die wahrheit in
war
jetzt sind zu enthalten aber ich bin
diesem satz an ist heute gut gelaunt da
haben sie schon auf jeden fall zwei
sinne von seien enthalten in diesem ist
es ist es doppeldeutig also einmal
natürlich wie ist sie sie ist gut
gelaunt aber dann natürlich auch noch
was im ganzen enthalten ist sie ist
wirklich gut gelaunt weil das behaupte
ich also hier ist der etat tiefere
wahrheit sinnvoll sein auch enthalten
also sie sehen diese sinne von sein
überlappen sich und wenn sie von sätzen
sprechen ist eigentlich immer der
wahrheit sind schon unterschwellig
impliziert weil sie ja nicht was
behaupten können sinnvoll ohne die
wahrheit vorauszusetzen sonst würden sie
erlitten aber auch da machen sie von
wahrheit begriff gebraucht das scheint
ein sehr zentraler war zentraler science
begriff zu sein das kann man sich
natürlich weiter gedanken machen wie
hängen diese verschiedenen sinne von
seien miteinander zusammen wollen wir
uns jetzt nicht weiter mit befassen für
uns im seminar ist vor allem wie gesagt
diese frage von interessen dress der
sinn im sinne der existenz was bedeutet
es etwas zu existieren genau das ist so
sind die verschiedenen sinne von sein
und jetzt möchte ich ihnen kurz noch was
einführen und sagen zum heutigen thema
wir haben gesagt wie sandra und thomas
von aquin das ist der absender ein
islamisches philosoph und dann thomas
von aquin ein christlicher philosoph und
jetzt haben wir ein paar leitfragen uns
überlegt beide philosophen sind
natürlich dem mittelalter im weitesten
sinne zu zeichnen also wie bestimme navi
senna und thomas energien dass sein
wir könnten hier auch gleich bedeutend
sagt existenz wie verhalten sich ihre
und theologin zu denjenigen bei platon
und aristoteles und jetzt kommt eine
ganz entscheidende frage inwiefern trend
thomas von aquin in klammern auch noch
wie senna das wisent die essenz ihrer
das lateinisch also es ist das wesen von
der existenz der existenz
ja das sind die wichtigsten fragen und
die letzte ist besonders wichtig und
jetzt möchte ich auch noch ihnen kurz
was erklären was gar nicht so leicht zu
verstehen ist wenn sie es mit
mittelalterlicher philosophie zu tun
haben
dann kommen diese begriffe immer mal
wieder und die sind gar nicht klar also
wir haben hier ein uni wo können einen
analogen und ein äquivalent science
begriff der immer wieder verwickelt wird
und jetzt können sie damit sicherlich
nichts anfangen ich konnte es auch nicht
am anfang also diese wörter gehört hat
diese begriffe gelesen habe was ist
damit gemeint was halt was hat man es
mit uni wo kamps science begriff zu tun
das will ich ihnen noch kurz erklären
der uni wo es einst begriff bedeutet das
wort sein oder existieren wird den blick
auf alle dinge auf dieselbe weise
verwendet also alles was existiert
existiert auf dieselbe weise
es kann größer kleiner sein und so
weiter aber es ist auf dieselbe art und
weise also alle dinge existieren auf
dieselbe weise sind auf dieselbe weise
sein sein und existenz ist das allgemein
sste merkmal aller dinge wenn wir von
allen eigenschaften der dinge ihrer
essenz absehen bleibt die existenz übrig
als sie mögen sich noch so sehr
hinsichtlich ihres wesens unterscheiden
am ende sind sie existieren sie und zwar
im evoque also im selben sinn auf
dieselbe weise das ist deswegen jetzt
interessant weil es gibt noch einen
anderen zeitbegriff und zwar ist es die
woge science begriff der sagt jetzt
genau das gegenteil
das sagt bedeutet das wort sein
existieren wird mit blick auf alle dinge
auf ganz verschiedene weise verwendet
das wort sein klingt nur gleich denken
sie an dieses spiel teekesselchen das
kennen sie bestimmt alle da sagen sie
dann bank und bank und meinen damit was
ganz anderes
einmal meinen sie damit eine
sitzgelegenheit ein andermal ein
geldinstitut das ist auch bezeichnet man
auch linguistisch als homo know me also
da haben sie eben nur denselben
wortklang
oder dieselbe schreibweise aber die
bedeutung ist eine verschiedene also das
bedeutet alle dinge existieren auf
verschiedene weise sind auf verschiedene
weise seien
das ist der weg wie vogue science
betrifft jetzt gibt es eben noch zum
schluss den analogen science begriff der
ist auch ganz interessant das sind alles
jetzt wichtige mittelalterliche
unterscheidung mittelalterliche unter
logi das wort sein existieren wird mit
blick auf alle dinge auf verwandte weiß
verwendet ist also so eine art zwischen
weg zwischen niveau compliance begriff
vor der science begriff auf dieselbe
weise verwendet wird und dem privaten
science begriff wohl auf völlig
verschiedene weise verwendet wird da
versucht jetzt analog des seins begriff
zu vermitteln das sagt heißt es auf
einem verwandten der analoge weise gibt
es gewisse ähnlichkeit intensität des 1
alle dinge existieren auf verschiedene
weise sind auf verschiedene weise in
verschiedenen gerade seien das ist jetzt
auch noch interessant alle die analogie
besteht in dieser im grad der existenz
an was erinnert sie das klar wenn sie
zurückdenken an die letzten sitzung das
ist natürlich ganz ähnlich wie bei
platon und aristoteles die zumindest bei
platon wenn sie noch mal an die ideen
denken die ideen die existieren auf eine
extrem intensive weise und die dinge die
an ihn teilhaben wie jetzt die bäume in
der physikalischen welt und biologischen
wild die existieren auch aber eben an
geringeren gerade und weil sie es jetzt
mit geraden zu tun haben können sie das
seien in einem verhältnis bringen in
eine analogie eben in mehr oder weniger
oder höher in einer höheren gerade in
einem geringeren gerade dass die analoge
science begriffe ja und da haben sie
jetzt verschiedene science begriffe mal
kennengelernt und sie haben auch
kennengelernt
die unterscheidung zwischen existenz
also design und der essenz dem wesen
häufig wird auch
wie essen gesprochen im sinne der form
das ist auch häufig eine
mittelalterliche redeweise